I was just surprised that people were so
prepared this season yeah like really
prepared like they uh it seems like they
studied the show like the first season
but yeah I guess doesn't mean makes
sense being that they're competing so
yeah I mean it's always you know it's
always hard I try to be constructive and
I always try to help them so I want them
to know where I come from and I try to
tell them what I think they can do
better at I try to see each contestant
as an individual brand and not that
everyone has to do the same kind of
thing we're asking them to do stuff
that's out of their comfort zone but to
the same time the same degree I'm like
okay I think you're this person and I
think you can do better at this part so
I'm trying to get more constructive in
that and looking at it from that kind of
criticism because I think that
ultimately whether they win or lose is
going to be what helps them with
subscribers and what helps them with
their channel yeah I watched the video I
assess how it makes me feel inside you
know and that's a part of it like it
makes me laugh makes me happy makes me
feel a certain way it doesn't always
have to make me laugh but you know just
as a package like we've we've touched on
this like you just kind of have to um I
would look at people like do I want to
go back and keep watching this person
you know cuz at the end of the day
that's what the whole internet icon
thing was about you know cuz you can
make an awesome video that goes viral
will get a 10 million views and then no
one will care about your channel anymore
you know but if you're that that person
that people just want to keep going back
to watch that's when you're like okay
this is the internet icon you know my
big thing I've always come from a
background of storytelling everyone
knows this so you know while something
can be totally random and and crazy and
ridiculous to a degree if everything is
random and crazy and ridiculous for me I
don't see how that's going to grow your
channel if you if you have something
that you can build a story off of even
if it's a three minute story even if
there's just a little tiny beginning
middle and end I think that shows me
that you understand content so in the
future if you're branching out from you
know a video that people really like or
a character that people really like
that's something that you can build off
of into a web series into something you
can monetize so that's where I'm always
coming from because I think that's
what's going to actually make people
money eventually yeah I think it's good
that we have like Christine and because
she differs from loss to you know and I
think what's good about what she does is
that you know like people have been
saying you know it's the Internet is
becoming more and more about I'm gonna
say story times in general but it's
becoming more you know like what's the
word for it like people are from the
mainstream industry are coming I don't
want to say the whole idea yeah and like
that's true waiters are starting to hold
the key yeah yeah you know it's not
people with money anymore that are
saying oh I want to source these people
to you work on my project its content
creators creating their own stuff that
other people are saying oh crap you're
actually really good can I would you do
this can I buy you what would you come
and work for us so I think I think a lot
of the power is being now trickled back
to people it shifts probably every 20
years it used to be big networks and now
I think it's you know it's the
individual that was three as an
up-and-coming youtuber you know I feel
like it's definitely gonna get more and
more difficult to get seen because
there's so many kids trying to do it now
you know like now you know when I
started I want it to be on you know on
TV and stuff you know that was my goal
now these kids they're like I want to be
a famous youtuber you know so they're
out there trying to be youtubers so it's
gonna get so difficult to just stick out
but I feel like what you when you have
quality content and someone sees it it
will get shared you know so it's like
just you know just really try and get
good at your craft and um and and try
and be unique if you can and and and you
really I know how to network to you know
if you know how to talk to people sure
right now yeah yeah right now it's like
you have to know everyone you have to do
collabs like it's so much harder to get
noticed now mm-hmm
one of VidCon I mean getting in those
groups of people knowing people I think
that that's that's always really helpful
I think it's also helpful to stay
relevant know what's going on in the
world you know like a viral video is
viable because it hits at the right time
that's holy and people that pick up on
trends and do something well and make
fun of something well that's why Sarah
nightlife continues to to be on the air
I'm it's because it's so timely so I
think that that's important yeah you
just have to be able to adapt I think
that's one of the biggest things is
because YouTube is always changing you
know their algorithm
the way that people find people on
YouTube is always changing some things
you just have to adapt like before it
was all about you know you make one
quality video and you make it to the top
front page and people find you like that
right now now it might be it's more
based on watch time so you make longer
videos
I mean it's built obviously like to help
gamers out you know because you can see
like they have those long 10 minute
videos or 20 minute videos of them just
playing the game but I mean you got to
adapt to what YouTube is giving you and
I just say like Tim said just keep
making quality content do what you think
is good as opposed to what you think is
good for you but also keep in mind you
know the algorithms that work if it's
what you love keep doing it
never give up just never ever give up
because there's gonna be a lot of people
that are gonna tell you you're not good
enough you're not good at it you're not
worth it you can't do it you know and
there's gonna be way more obstacles in
your way but you just keep pushing and
then eventually you'll get there I I
went to film school and what that did
was it gave me a lot of connections um
I don't think I learned a lot or at
least I haven't figured out how to
manipulate that knowledge yet but most
of its from Google and YouTube and I
just like for a period of four my most
of my college career I wouldn't do
anything except just work work work work
work work and I know my wife can attest
to that and my family can attest to that
because I wouldn't really go out and
party I wouldn't really go see friends I
wouldn't do that I mean and that's
that's a sacrifice you have to make if
if you want to really if you want it
that bad so I just you know once I felt
I was good enough at a certain area I'm
like okay so now let's do music so it's
it's really difficult because for a
while there I mean like any director
likes to hide behind the lens and like
it's kind of really difficult to like
push yourself in front of the lens and
say hey this is me but I think the fear
of failure leads to failure so if you
don't just do it and commit to it it's
gonna be a lot harder I feel like with
YouTube it's another opportunity to
create a canvas but one that's not
specific to commercial breaks not
specific to whether or not how the
feature is going to be released
our partner on this Justin Lin direct of
course fast and furious and had a huge
movie with the new Fast and Furious this
year and you spend all your time in
those meetings what's amazing about
YouTube and amazing about a show like
this and someone like Matthias or the
Clunes are bad whether any of our
contestants the meeting is kind of with
your own mind you have to have sort of
the desire to get up on Saturday morning
and film hey who's gonna bring the
aluminum foil and hey I need a dog and
by the way I need for actors and does
anybody have a dad who can come do it
like so you are a producer you're a
director you're an editor you're a music
composer you're casting you're writing
and so it teaches you a lot of skills
whether or not it becomes applicable to
a lot of the youtubers I don't know if
they necessarily want to be involved in
Hollywood part of them I think enjoy
just simply vlogging and turning on and
being like hey look at me I've been
doing this for three years and when I
talk to them and they tell me their
schedule and I'm like really wait what
and then but then they ask me my
schedule and they're like really wait
why so I feel like what they are
learning though is production and what's
really clear especially content
providers like Ryan and Timothy and all
of our amazing judges that we had the
fan base expects you to deliver so if
you do a video and then two months later
you haven't delivered anything the
fickle world of Youtube subscriber like
I'm gonna go look at somebody else if
you can keep churning out content good
content that addresses the needs of your
target audience
then you're learning a remarkable skill
and you're gonna be able to translate it
as we look at sort of the millennial
generation if we look at as these kids
are growing up the question is I look
I'm I'm old so I grew up with MTV MTV
was my world it was my everything I
raced home saw every show on MTV I still
when I would watch the you know the real
world/road rules challenge is that's
what it was called now it's just called
the challenge cuz Road rules isn't on
but they still have people from Road
rules and now they and then they're
considered the old people and then I'm
like
I must turn this off now and just lie
down and die so will YouTube grow with
that well will those fans when you know
will they become 40 years old and still
be subscribing and wanting to grown so I
think that's the what's amazing and
exciting about the future and another
challenge for a lot of these people like
everything we do in Hollywood there's
good stuff and there's crap and on
YouTube there's plenty of stuff where
I'm like that is amazing there's plenty
of stuff where I'm like really I must
call that person and please ask them to
just give that camera to someone else
and never pick it up but that's the
beauty of the creative community I was
lucky enough to be the mentor version of
the house so I got to really hang out
with the contestants and they were all
so amazing so creative so different you
know and a lot of times I was just
encouraging them to to continue like to
keep fighting like because you get to
this point where you're going you're
going you're going like every day you're
you're draining every piece of energy
you have both mentally and physically
and then you got to get up and create
another thing right the next day and
like you literally get like depressed
and frustrated you know it's production
stuff you know I'm like I found myself a
lot of times just like encouraging him
like it's gonna be alright you know like
you are good this is good like and then
you lose sense of like what's funny
anymore you know so it's a lot of that
kind of stuff but it was just really
cool to really give them like actual
experience advice you don't I mean like
I've been here so here's here's what you
got an experience like yeah
don't stress get it done hustle to the
plate you don't even like just just
don't worry about it it was it was good
to be that guy you know I mean we got a
lot of stuff we have a big announcement
coming August 1st very big announcement
stay tuned stay tuned for that interweb
but yeah I mean right now I mean we're
just committed to Ken you know trying to
make content that we love on our channel
which is very strange
maybe ends in a fart joke too often but
growing up no no no but yeah I mean I
think that's really what we're striving
for and I mean if season 3 if they'll
have us back I mean we'll see where it
goes with you it would be a blast to get
in there and go wild again so it is
definitely a fun environment yeah so
somebody please call me Andy fickman I'm
here or maybe bad weather we'll just
toast that next year honestly honestly
bad idea like they're so funny like they
would do it well yeah I feel like we
would have a lot of fun doing it again
but I feel like if it's like a doctor
who kind of thing
stop you know and then it's like oh this
is the next you know version it'd be
great and they just chaos or I mean
think about Mitch I mean the nudity of
that show alone would be phenomenal the
ratings would be through the roof it
just does it completely completely naked
the entire time it's not naked and
afraid' or once they get afraid they get
afraid
yum yum f is has this video for geek
week that I play Google executive
teaching Yaya math how to be more Asian
and I'm white are you so what that's
where the irony comes from but ya know
what's really funny and then my good
friends Josh and Jacob who are there
beside me and they just kind of take it
way too far
it's a musical so it goes really far
near future I will actually have a
schedule for my videos I'm trying to do
that so I mean like trying to plan it
out I might do like advice like
relationship advice or just advice on
life blogs
i'ma trying to sketch it I'm not real
good at sketching if you notice I mean I
made dumb stuff like The Exorcist or
whatever exercisers a terrible terrible
video yes aw I'm gonna try and keep
doing that hope you guys enjoy check it
out youtube.com slash yellow Baco you